- Hey Gary, my name is Richard.
- [Gary] Hey Richard.
- My daughter's 17,
she's going to a meeting
tonight with my wife,
- Yes.
- to discuss with her school,
her university options.
What she wants to do.
She's incredibly courageous.
Marketing mind, communications mind.
I'm taping you right now,
and I'd like do you to talk to her,
like she was your 17 year old daughter.
In terms of how she should
consider her university career.
How she should maximize that experience,
to prepare her for the world,
that you see she may be entering into.
- Oof...
(crowd applauds)
Um...
so...
- Her name is Kiara.
- Kiara, I have no idea
what's about to happen,
but it's about to get interesting, Kiara.
Here's what I would say, Kiara.
I would tell you that there's
not a school on Earth,
not a university or college that exists,
that is even remotely equipped,
to educate you properly,
on communications and marketing,
in the world we live in today.
So, I have no interest, Kiara,
(crowd applauds)
to get your mom and dad mad at me,
but, I would tell you,
(crowd laughs)
that here would be my four year strategy.
I would go to university, especially--
Is she going here in Canada?
- [Richard] She's talking about NYU.
She's talking about San Fran'.
- Is she collecting debt,
or are you guys paying for it?
- [Richard] I think she's
just enamored by big brands.
- But is she gonna pay for college?
- [Richard] Yeah, well we're--
yeah. We're paying for it.
- So she's not collecting debt?
- [Richard] No. Well yeah--
I apologize. We're paying for it, and yes,
she's gonna have to
collect debt along the way.
- All right, Kiara.
You're gonna have to
have a weird conversation
with your mom and dad.
(crowd laughs)
Because the first thing
I'm passionate about,
is for you to not have any debt.
Because if you're gonna go to a business,
that is going to sell you a shit product,
that you are then gonna
pay compounded interest in,
that you can't even declare
bankruptcy to get out of,
that's called extortion
fucked-up, fucking crazy-ass shit.
(crowd applauds)
But...
but, Kiara,
if that number's not that high,
and you can get some other things,
that drives down that cost.
The second move would be,
to take your last four
year vacation of your life.
Hookup a whole bunch
- [Crowd] Oh!
(crowd laughs)
- Or! Or not a--
You know, depending on
your own radar, Kiara.
That might be one dude, seven.
That's on you; don't let them judge.
- [Richard] She's a nice,
good Christian girl now
- I'm sure she is.
(Richard laughs)
(crowd laughs)
And if you want to learn about
marketing and communications,
Spend a lot of time online,
and consume relevant 2017 content.
From people that are actually doing it,
not professors that are so not practical,
and so romantic of how it used be.
That I've traveled the best
universities in the world,
and have literally thrown
up all over myself,
while I've been prepped to talk,
listening to the horse-shit,
that those professors are
shoving down these kids throats.
(crowd applauds)
- [Richard] Thanks, Gary!
- You're welcome, brother! Love you.
(upbeat electronic music)